لدي ذاكرة جيدة جدًا لذا لا أستطيع أن
أتذكر
تمامًا كل تلك الاختبارات، كما
تعلم، أتذكر الكثير من النهائيات
التي كنت أرغب في مشاهدتها والتي تعلم أنني
لا أستطيع ذلك، لذا سأذهب إلى المدرسة وأذهب
إلى اليوتيوب وأشاهدها
إنهم في فصل الكمبيوتر بالتأكيد
نعم نعم
في ذلك الوقت مثل الكذب والأشياء التي
سيسمحون لي بالدخول إليها وبعد ذلك سأذهب
وأشاهد وبعد ذلك سأطلب من
زملائي في الفصل أن يخبروني أوه نعم
حدث هذا أنا معجب بنعم  نعم لقد رأيت
ذلك نعم
أوه
ولكن لأكون صادقًا لأكون في هذا
الموقف الآن
لأكون عائلتي هناك، فأنت تعلم أنه
سيكون شيئًا جميلًا لأنه حينها يبدو الأمر
كما لو
أنني لم أتمكن من المشاهدة
ولكن الآن
أنت تعرف بفضل نعمة  يا إلهي، يمكنني أن ألعب مباراة
واحدة،
إنه شيء جميل، أنت تعرف أن اللعب
ربما ضد أفضل أفضل فريق
في العالم في الواقع، لذلك أريد فقط
الاستمتاع باللعبة، كما تعلم بصراحة،
جدك الذي قلته هو
أهم شخص بالنسبة لك بعد والدتك.
وأبي بالطبع إذا كنت من
الكونغو، نعم آسف،
نعم،
ما رأيك في هذه اللحظة
كثيرًا
[موسيقى]
أم
أسوأ شيء هو عندما أرى ابني
أرى الكثير منه عندما يكون لدي
صورة لي  جدي على الواتساب
وعندما أنظر إلى ابني الأصغر
يبدو أنه يشبهه كثيرًا لذا
تعلم أه جدي هنا من أجلي هو
كان رقم واحد بالنسبة لي
كان رقم واحد بالنسبة لي لقد
كان اه من
أكبر المعجبين بي من أكبر المعجبين بي
لذا كل  الوقت الذي ألعب فيه،
نعم، لا
بأس، نعم بالنسبة له، إنه من أجله،
نمر بالكثير في
مسيرتنا المهنية وأحيانًا لا
يعرف الناس حجم الإنجاز، لذا
عندما تصل إلى لحظة مثل هذه، فهي
تمر طوال الوقت
بالنسبة لـ  البنات سجلوا كل
مشاكلنا التي نظرت إليها كنت
أعتني بأمي عندما كان عمري 12 عامًا
فعلت ذلك
لذلك في
كل مرة عندما أنظر إلى أمي
وأرى في المدرجات أشعر
وكأنني أنظر إليه بعد كل إله
وقل وكأنني
فعلت ذلك، لقد فعلت ذلك،
لا يهم كما لو كنت تعلم أنك تفوز
بالخسائر،
كما تعلم أن تتحمل خجولتي، كما تعلم أن
هذه مشكلة عائلية حقيقية، لذا
فأنت تعلم أن هذا بالنسبة لي كان يعني
العالم بالنسبة لي، تقصد  العالم بالنسبة
لي، أنت تعني العالم بالنسبة للكثير من
اللاعبين وأتمنى لكم كل التوفيق،
شكرًا لكم على هذا النهائي، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم